-Our first guest tonight is
a Golden Globe-winning actress
you know from shows like
"Felicity" and "The Americans."
She stars in "Antlers,"
which is in theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-He's not dead.
-Yeah, he is, Lucas.
My brother, Paul --
he found him in your house.
-No.
That was my old dad,
when he was sick and mean.
My new dad's related,
but Aiden doesn't understand,
and he needs me.
I just have to feed him,
and he'll love me.
-Please welcome back to the show
Keri Russell!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hi!
-Hello! Welcome back!
It's so good
to see you in person.
-I know.
-I like a horror movie where
a scene takes place by fireside.
-It's very similar
to how you parent, right?
You're like, "Give me food, and
then you'll stay alive."
-Yep. I also --
Every hard conversation
I have with my kids, I'm like,
"You sit on the couch.
I'll start a fire.
One side of my face
will be very ghostly lit."
-It always works better
that way, always.
-This film
takes place in Oregon,
and it is sort of
a ravished community --
a ravaged community,
I should say.
-I think I'm ravishing.
-You're ravishing.
-Ravishing.
-You're a ravishing woman
in a ravaged community.
But it's got
a supernatural element.
It's a scary film.
Have you seen it in the theater?
That's one of the exciting
things about people
being to be to get in theaters
again is scary movies.
-It is, and I'm really glad
they held it,
because, you know, we actually
made this three years ago,
or about that,
and then, as we all know,
the world stopped working
for a moment.
And so they saved it, and then
we could see it in theaters,
which, by the way, you know,
this definitely should be
seen in theaters, and it's so
beautiful and haunting.
But, yes, I have these girl pals
that my kids
call "Moms Gone Wild."
-Your kids call you
"Moms Gone Wild"?
Wow.
-Correct.
-These mom friends of mine.
And we took --
The Moms Gone Wild friends
took our teenagers to go see
this movie last Saturday,
and it was scarier
than I thought.
-The movie -- That's good.
-I hadn't seen it
in three years,
and I was like, "Ooh!
This is -- Whoa! This is -- Wow!
This a lot scarier
than I thought."
And I kept looking over
at the teenagers,
and they were like, "It's fine."
-Really?
-Yeah.
-So the Moms Gone Wild
were scared,
but the teenagers were fine.
-Moms Gone Wild -- You know,
when you see a scary movie,
they always show
scary-movie trailers.
-Yep.
-So, there was
a "Scream" trailer at first,
and there's this
very scary teaser to it.
And the two of us verbally
screamed and bonked our heads.
We went "Aah!" and screamed
and bonked our heads,
and the teenagers looked at
us like, "Hey."
Like, "Get out of here."
-Your kids are so spread out --
14, 9, and 5.
-9 and 5, yep.
-So, what is Halloween like when
you have kids that are, like,
so different in
the eras of life there?
-I'm so glad I survived.
-Yeah.
-It's exhausting.
Does anyone else
have exhausting Halloweens?
-Yeah.
-I mean, I know it's fun,
and I grew up with a mom
who loved Halloween and,
like, is so into all of that.
It's exhausting.
You know, the teenagers are out.
You're trying to make sure
they're safe.
The 9-year-old, you're like,
"Got to get them
with their friends,
make sure no one
gets kidnapped."
I mean, it's,
like, people everywhere --
-And did you -- Did she get
kidnapped or did you make it?
-Not this year.
-Okay. Congrats.
-And then the 5-year-old
is Darth Vader,
and he's, like, running around.
It was craziness.
I'm so tired from Halloween.
-I -- We are trying to --
You know, 'cause 5 is our
oldest, and 5 is your youngest.
So, we're trying to,
like, teach him that, like,
eating the candy
isn't actually part of this.
-Oh, no.
-Yeah, you leave
the candy on offer
for the Halloween Santa.
-You know what?
That's so funny, because that's
kind of what Matthew does.
-Yeah.
-And, actually,
he went out last night,
and I had all
three kids home alone.
And Matthew was
getting ready to go,
and I was like,
"You guys, if you are good,
if you are good, I will let you
guys have a piece of candy
after dinner."
And they were like, "Whoo!"
And I was like, "Keep it down!
Keep it down!
If Matt hears, he's going to be
really bummed."
So, he left,
and they were like, "Candy!"
-Yeah. It's not fair
what they do us with the candy.
-It's not fair.
It's really not fair,
but it's amazing.
-Your husband,
Matthew Rhys, who --
You guys met on "The Americans."
-It's true.
-And he -- A lot of people did
stuff during the pandemic.
Was this a -- He bought a boat.
-On eBay.
-Yeah.
-Which is, like --
I would imagine most boaters
would say that's not
the place to buy it.
-I'd say that's not
the place to buy a boat.
-And he had to do
a lot of work on it.
-Especially for someone
who had never had a boat before.
-Okay.
-He was like,
"Oh, this is a good idea."
Like, probably
after two glasses of wine
on the couch late at night.
-Yeah. The weird thing
is that he --
I mean, 'cause, again, like,
it's not like eBay is like,
"Hey, you want to look
at a boat?"
Like, you have to go on eBay
and, like, enter "boat."
-Oh, he deep-dived it.
-Yeah.
-He deep-dived it, yeah.
-And he bought a boat
and he had to do a ton of work.
Like, this is him,
like, doing work on his boat.
But, like, there was
an article in
"The New York Times" about this.
-There was.
-This is a successful boat.
It's the same kind of boat that
Ernest Hemingway had, correct?
-Correct. There's only four left
in the world of that class.
-Wow. And here it is.
Look at the job
he did on this boat.
-I know. It's really good.
Him and his captain, Kelli.
And the thing that sold it
was that the name
actually on the boat.
Its given name was Rarebit.
-Oh, it pre-existed.
-It pre-existed.
You don't -- It's very bad luck
to change the name of a boat.
-Really?
-And when he heard
it was Rarebit,
there's this food thing
called Welsh rarebit.
And he was like,
"I have to have this boat."
-Yeah, because he's a Welshman.
-Yeah.
-He's proud Welshman.
-And I was like, "Good luck."
-Now, has he won you over?
Because this now seems like
a lovely way to, like,
go around --
-It is a lovely way.
And it's beautiful.
It's this beautiful antique
wooden thing
that we want to do
"Day Drinking" with you.
-Yeah, I would love to go
day-drinking on the sea.
-Yes, right?
-Yeah, 'cause that's where --
The only thing that --
When I've gone day-drinking,
the only thing
I've wished was also happening
was just being slowly jostled.
Just a light, slow jostling.
-A lot of our dreams
can come true together.
-Well, I'm going
to hold you guys to this.
-You will.
-It is always great to see you.
Congratulations so much
on the film.
You guys, that's Keri Russell.
"Antlers" is in theaters now.